an insight into the difference between
this way of formulating a law and
previous forms will make its nature
perfectly clear if namely we look back
to the movement of perceiving and to
that of the understanding in which the
latter reflects itself into itself and
thereby determines its object we see
that the understanding does not in that
movement have before itself in its
object the relation of these abstract
determinations of universal and
individual essential and external it is
itself the transition which does not
become objective to it here on the
contrary the organic unity which is just
the relation of those opposites this
relation being a pure transition is
itself the object this transition in its
simplicity is immediately universality
and since this universality explicate
the different moments whose relation is
to express the law it's moments are
universal objects of this consciousness
and the law runs the outer is the
expression of the inner here the
understanding is grasped the thought of
the law itself whereas previously it
only looked for laws generally and their
moments were only vaguely present to it
as a specific content but not as the
thoughts of the laws as regards content
the law is obtained here ought not to be
such as are merely a passive taking up
into the form of universality of simply
inert differences but laws which
directly possess in these differences
the unrest of the notion and
consequently at the same time possess
the necessity of the relation between
the aspects but just because the object
the organic unity directly unites the
infinite supersession or absolute
negation of being with an art being and
because the moments are essentially a
pure transition there are no
such a nerd aspects as are required for
the law
in this paragraph number 279 it seems as
if Hagel is in certain respects raising
our hopes giving us perhaps some false
hopes that are going to be very quickly
disappointed because he moves through
this paragraph and that into the
following paragraphs Hagel is still
explaining to us why it is that the
conception of law that we typically have
been working with isn't really adequate
to deal with organic beings and he
suggests at this point that we take a
look into the difference between this
way of formulating a walk the way of
formulating law for organic beings and
the previous forms he says this will
make its nature perfectly clear so he
says if we look back to the movement of
perceiving that is perception Barnum in
the understanding so that's the force
and the understanding section in which
the latter reflects itself back into
itself thereby determines its out so we
have we have perceiving perception of
the outside world no longer just sent
certainty but perception perception of
universals grasping things that are
there right that was an understanding
and understanding naturally wants to try
to make sense out of not just this
particular thing but the totality and to
make sense of things of that that type
to give them laws and then Tim was that
unify other laws we saw this entire
movement in the force in the
understanding section so he says in this
case the ladder reflects itself into
itself and thereby determines its object
we see the understanding does not can
before it's of these these things here
right the relation of these abstract
determinations of universal and
individual or essential and external and
that seems kind of a strange thing for
Hegel to say because if we think
to the force and the understanding
section think back to the play of when
we had two forces right one of which was
externalized one of which was force in
itself right or you know we have many
individuals all being brought under one
we could call it a universal for so what
what is he ghal going on about here he
says that what understanding ends up
realizing is that it it is itself the
transition which does not then become
objective to it so we saw that this did
in fact take place in the forest and the
understanding section that understanding
after while started to realize that this
whole notion of forces and laws in even
worlds you know need to distinguish
these these worlds apart from each other
that aren't really separated from each
other that the understanding is really
what's driving this entire process and
so Hagel talk here about a transition
taking place within it he says it is
itself the transition which does not
become objective to it so understanding
that has to examine itself and that's
when we shifted you remember from
consciousness into the whole self
consciousness section right so if we go
on from there he says here on the
counter the organic unity where the
organic unity is encompassing all of
this and it's also taking into account
these abstract determinations which are
turning out not to be quite so abstract
in the organic being they are the way
that it is he says here the organic
unity is just the relation of those
opposites this relation being itself a
pure transition and being the object and
we saw that the organic being is
somewhat different in that it is its own
right how is it its own object was it a
practical sense oriented towards action
continuing its being doing what it needs
to do in order to augment its being in
relation to other beings and it's its
environment so this is a important
transition point he says this is
immediately universality so we can say
that this is something that that's you
know holding in all these cases so this
universality explicate the different
moments whose relation is to express the
law its moments are universal objects of
this consciousness and the law notice
what law we have here runs the outer is
the expression of the inner we have
restored at least for the moment this
law that we have been trying to grapple
with and make sense up right we saw all
sorts of problems with it in the
previous period rest now it looks like
Hagel is bringing it back he's even
going to speak more optimistically as we
continue in this paragraph with all this
talking about law about now we're not
just grasping the content in health of
the law we're actually grasping the
thought of the law sounds pretty good
doesn't it he says here the
understanding has grasped the thought
the thought of the law itself whereas
previously it only looked for laws
generally and their moments were only
vaguely present it as a specific
specific content sorry about that but
now he has the thoughts of the laws so
what is he saying there he's saying that
something greater has has come about
some sort of integration in which
because now we're talking about an
organic unity which involves at least
for human beings right consciousness the
understanding now suddenly understanding
has grasped the thought of the law no
longer just
tenth of the law or the multiplicity of
was but it's actually you know groping
for what the hell is law and why does it
matter to me it's broaching these larger
in certain respects more fundamental or
essential crushes or issues now notice
what he's going to say though he says he
has regards content the laws of the teen
here ought not to be such as our Emir
merely a passive taking up into the form
of universality of simply inert
differences right just merely a nerd
differences of content we saw that
merely and her differences can't grasp
what's going on in the organic being
either how does this going to play out
he says the laws which directly
possessed in these differences the
unrest of the notion the the unrest the
the not staying still the dynamism is
another way we could talk about it
instead of talking about a merely
negative terms unrest Moruga right not
being static let's call it dynamic let's
call it what it is this is what goes on
with an organic being it should be
grasping the notion and at the same time
possess the necessity of the relation
between the object so what does Hagel
saying if you're not grasping the notion
you're not actually grasping the
necessity law was supposed to be about
necessity right supposed to explain why
things necessarily are the way that they
are so he goes on and he says but
because the object the organic unity
directly and eerie sing its uniting
things right unite the the infinite
supersession the our a bone or absolute
negation of being what are we talking
about there well you know the organic
being is being but it's being raised to
a higher level it's it's a negation of
getting in so far as it's not merely
being not merely static being but a
dynamic being that that grows that that
responds that interact that the develops
complexity within it that shows
spontaneity to historic son's freedom to
a certain extent so all of these units
that with inert being that sounds pretty
good doesn't it it sounds as if now
we're finally on the right track as far
as this whole process of finding laws
which is what observing reason is all
about it is doing now notice how he
closes the paragraph he says just
because the object does all this and
because these moments are essentially
pure transition there are no such inner
aspects as are required for the law so
we have the thought of the law and
actually what are we losing the content
all right the content is slipping out of
our hands insofar as it is just in our
differences or a nerd contents or
whatever we want to say it's no longer
about the organic unity it insofar as
it's about the organic unity it can no
longer be expressed solely in those
terms for us Hagel is going to continue
to explore this a bit more in the next
paragraphs
in order to
such aspects the understanding must keep
to the other moment of the organic
relationship that is to the
reflectiveness of organic existence into
itself but this being is so completely
reflected into itself that there is no
determinate pneus related to something
else left over for it immediate sensuous
being is immediately one with the
determinate nas's such and therefore
express is a qualitative difference in
that being for example blue as against
red acid is against alkali and so on but
organic being that is returned into
itself is completely indifferent towards
an other its existence is a simple
universality and it denies to
observation any lasting sensuous
differences or what is the same thing
displays it's essential determinate
pneus only as the flocks of inert
determinate nas's consequently the way
in which difference quite andert
expresses itself is just this that it is
an indifferent difference that is
differences magnitude in this however
the notion is extinguished and necessity
has vanished but then the content and
filling of this in different being the
flux of sensuous determinations gathered
up into an organic determination
expresses also this that the content
really does not have that determinate
pneus that is that of the immediate
property and the qualitative element
Falls solely in the determination of
magnitude as we saw above
what's taking place in paragraph 280 can
be a little bit difficult to follow
there's a lot of jumping back and forth
that that's happening and I think it
could be useful to turn it out like like
this so that we can see that there's
actually a sort of the third thing being
introduced here when we're contrasting
the first two Hinkle is asking this this
question at the start how I can be
understanding get these inert aspects
the inert aspects that in the previous
paragraph he said just we're not
available for developing a law
consciousness absorbing reason is still
attempting to provide it's off with some
sort of law it's just you know the last
paragraph brought back up the the outer
is the expression of the inner it really
wants to try to make that work and so
we're going to see another attempt at
this Hagel's going to contrast the
notion of organic being against
immediate sensuous being and he says
that in order to obtain these aspects
the understanding the understanding must
keep to the other moment of the organic
relationship that is so the
reflectiveness of organic existence into
itself so that is this side the notion
of organic being and he says the problem
with this is that this being is is so
reflected into itself that there really
is no determinate Ness related to
something else like for example the
understanding that is trying to make
sense of it and this is just you know
sort of the notion i would say here in a
strata so it's not the notion as the
living notion the dynamic organic being
embodying that but what the
understanding is making of it he's
saying here that you know as we go
towards the inner and we look at say for
example you know those those 38
expressions of the inner before
sensibility durability reproduction we
start to lose
track because these are in fact a flocks
they are you know spread throughout the
entire organism itself the organic being
the existence of the organism we start
to lose hold on any in nerd moments that
we could grab onto almost as like you
know fixed points that then we could tie
the law to so they'll talk in terms of
simple universality here you'll also
chalk in terms of a flocks of in our
differences which is going to lead us to
that third part now Lizzie contrasting
against this a little bit earlier in the
paragraph he talks about immediate
sensuous being what it is that we
immediately perceive through the medium
of our senses not to say that it's
completely reducible to sense perception
or you know let alone just the
sensations that are occurring but what
is given to us and he says that
immediately it's it's determinate nas's
that we're getting right this is
presenting as this right and it's got
qualities known as he talks about
qualitative differences here sony text
for example about not even complete
opposites like blue it as it gets red
and then he talks about the acid is
against alkaline and he says organic
being that has returned to itself isn't
this it's this instead and he goes on he
says the way in which difference quiet
and nerve expresses itself is just this
that it is an indifferent difference and
we've seen this come up quite a lot
Hagel is going to make a move here that
he's made a number of points in the
phenomenology so far which is to say
what is indifferent difference what is
it to be different but in a way that
doesn't actually make a difference the
prime example that is magnitude or
quantity so moving from both sides we're
losing track or
losing what it is that we started out
with in trying to get these these
aspects where we can talk in terms of
the dynamic organic being which can be
understood as you just said before in
terms of the notion they have if we try
to hold on to it we wind up with these
in different differences because all we
have here is a flocks of inert
differences right immediate sensuous
being insofar as it remains immediate
sensuous being as a matter of
qualitative differences within this
whole you know booming buzzing confusion
you to leave James term determinate this
is but insofar as were making sense of
it we end up reducing it to it's merely
quantitative aspects so he goes out and
he says and this the notion is
extinguished right we lose the necessity
for just dealing with this we lose the
necessity that we were after in the
first place and it's vanished he said
the content and filling of this in
different being the flux of sensuous
determinations gathered up into an
organic determination expresses this the
content does not really have that
determinate pneus that is of the
immediate property and qualitative
element fall solely into the
determination of magnitude so we also
are going to lose this this is going to
turn into magnitude we're seeing
everything sort of funneling into
magnitude or quantity for the
understanding and this we've seen this
you know technique or strategy carried
out before but now we're seeing it on a
more global scale for the understanding
and the question is is that actually
going to be a successful strategy
although then the objective aspect which
is apprehended as an organic determinate
pneus itself contains the notion and is
thereby distinguished from the object as
it presents presents itself to the
understanding which in apprehending the
content of its laws behaves purely as
perception yet apprehension in the first
case relapses completely into the
principle and the manner of the
understanding that merely perceives for
by so doing what is apprehended receives
the character of a fixed determinate
pneus the form of an immediate property
or of an inert phenomenon furthermore it
is subsumed under the category of
quantity and the nature of the notion is
suppressed the exchange of an object
that is merely perceived from one
reflected into itself of a merely
sensuous determinate pneus for an
organic one thus loses once more its
value and does so by the fact that the
understanding has not yet put behind it
the formulating of laws
hinkle brings this line of criticism or
a reasoning if you like to a close in
281 paragraph 281 he's going to provide
examples of this in paragraph 282 so
he's just talking about the immediate
conclusion the form of what he's he's
described in here and he says the
objective the aspect which is
apprehended as an organic determinate
pneus contains the notion that's what
the understanding is is driving after in
trying to formulate its laws right and
is its apprehending things under the
framework of laws it's hoping to do
something different than actually is
going to happen it wants to take this as
its object but it ends up taking this
and this is you might say the reduced
aspect of the the hall the the husk the
shell of what this actually turns out to
be so he says it's there by
distinguished the this organic
determinist from the object as it
presents itself to the understanding
which as its amber handing the content
of its it through his laws right and I
was lost it behaves purely as perception
so understanding in a certain sense is
it's doing something that it is familiar
with remember that understanding just
like perception before it was an out
payable it was also a new gestalt the
shape of consciousness Randy we have the
lower shape that is taken up into the
higher shape or higher activity and in
this case understanding is not fully
acting as understanding you could say
it's reducing itself to perception what
is it that it does perceive them as
apprehending the content of its laws it
perceives what hable calls fix
determinate pneus right yeah this might
be in the form of an immediate property
which we saw could be qualitative right
or in a nerd phenomenon something that
presents itself it's something we say
okay I could work with this because it's
going to stay still right if we want to
use some examples just to try to drive
this one before we get to the next
paragraph think about as Hagel is
talking about before when we are working
with a catan when we're doing dissection
we're not actually working with the same
thing as observation of a live being we
suppose you could say well what about
vivisection well that's pretty horrible
stuff to begin with for a couple of
things but even that loses hold of it
because you're changing just by imposing
that kind of structure about it you're
not observing it as it is within its
environment when somebody's not cutting
it open with a scalpel when somebody
hasn't pinned it to a table whatever
whatever else is going on there's a kind
of falsification of the reality of the
organic thing that goes on in the
attempt to be scientific animals laws of
product so that is something very
important to keep in mind Hagel says
that what happens here is if the heat is
purely perceptual henshin in this case
relapse is completely into the principle
in manner of the understanding that
merely proceeds so whereas perception
should be a tool for understanding
you've got the tool driving the tool
master if you like that right
consciousness is kind of shifting itself
into a lower but more manageable shape
or activity he says for by so doing what
is apprehended receives the character
fix determining this right so that's
more malleable but it's losing sight of
its
sumed under the category of quantity and
the nature of the notion is thereby
suppressed in favor of quantity because
quantity is so manageable so he goes and
they says the exchange of an object that
is merely perceived right for one that's
reflected into itself of a merely
sensuous determinate pneus for an
organic one loses once more its value
and does so by the fact that the
understanding is not put behind it
formulating law so what does it lose it
giving us the idea maybe this whole
activity of formulating laws has been
misguided or at least the way in which
it has been conceived behind the
understanding the way in which has been
carrying out these laws has been
misconceived and therefore has been a
failure
you